si piensas que las ecuaciones son de
otro mundo entonces observe descubre
cómo están más cerca de lo que te
imaginabas pues aunque no lo creas es
posible y las podemos ver representadas
por medio de gráficas y algunas
construcciones en áreas como
arquitectura geología economía física y
otras más
por ejemplo plantear una ecuación te
ayudará a tomar una decisión más
acertada para calcular cuánto tiempo
tardaría en llegar a determinado lugar
si decides usar una bicicleta o el
autobús para llegar más rápido estás
comparando la distancia que recorre el
transporte y el tiempo de llegada en
esta gráfica podríamos ver ambas
variables representadas la d es la
distancia y la t el tiempo este tipo de
gráfica está trazada sobre un plano de
dos dimensiones
ahora imagina que necesitas establecer
la ruta entre dos puntos que se
encuentran en una montaña esta es una
situación donde encontramos aplicación
de ecuaciones con tres variables x y y
ceta por ejemplo para el trazo de esta
ruta es necesario emplear tres ejes
ordenados éstos nos ayudarán a graficar
los puntos donde se ubicarán nuestro
camino y la gráfica necesariamente debe
ser trazada sobre un sistema de
coordenadas de tres dimensiones en
arquitectura se emplea el trazo de
superficies cuadráticas sobre un sistema
coordinado tridimensional este tipo de
gráficas son de una ecuación de
polinomios de segundo grado en donde se
emplean variables como x y y ceta
veamos algunos ejemplos tenemos un
edificio en forma de esfera cuya gráfica
se vería de esta manera aquí una
construcción en forma de hiperboloide y
su gráfica y por último un edificio que
la forma de un cilindro elíptico con su
gráfica así que si creías que las
ecuaciones eran de otro mundo abandona
esa idea porque ya sabes que están más
cerca de lo que te imaginabas te reta
que encuentres más ecuaciones ocultas en
construcciones y gráficas